We consider the work done by
a gravitational force, which
was path-independent.
Now let's generalize that to
any force between two points,
i, and another point,
f, that if the work done
going from the initial
point to the final point--
this is path-independent--
then we call this
force a conservative force.
There are many
conservative forces
that we'll analyze
in this class.
Examples will be the inverse
square, electric force,
or the gravitational force.
We've already seen
gravitational force.
Near the surface of the
Earth is conservative.
Spring forces are other
examples of conservative forces.
But let's look a
little bit in detail.
Suppose we call
this path 1 and we
consider a second path, path 2.
Then a property of
conservative forces
is that the work done is
independent of that path.
So if we total up the
work from the initial
to final on path 1 of f dot ds.
And then we go from
the final point
to the initial point
on path 2 of f dot ds.
Then because these intervals
are independent of the path,
and all we've done is shifted
the endpoints, we get 0.
And that's the statement.
And we'll write w conservative
here for conservative forces.
So we're going to call
this force conservative
if it's path-independent.
So what we have here
is the statement
that the work done by
a conservative force.
Now what we'll do here,
is indicate a circle
by a closed path.
The work done by conservative
force on a closed path is zero.
What does a closed
path look like?
Well, remember, what we did
was we went from 1, but then
instead of going
in this direction,
we came back on path
to, from the final,
to the initial point.
And if the force
is conservative,
the work done around
a closed path is 0.